bueno muchas gracias ante todo por
tenerme y estoy de acuerdo con la
aplicación que se acaba de indicar
nosotros tuvimos una primera un primer
pico al principio de la pandemia con una
caída en el verano
y luego por una relajación de las
medidas de seguridad una falta en
realidad de mensaje claro de uso de
máscaras estacionamiento social vimos
otro segundo pico que se amesetó y ahora
estamos viendo un tercer un pequeño pico
un tercer pico comienzo del tal al
reabrir los coles las escuelas en muchos
lugares así que estamos ciertamente
preocupados por esto y esperemos que
realmente pronto logremos otra meseta
realmente pero creo que nos falta este
arma y hacer un incentivo general a la
población sobre la importancia del
distanciamiento social y del uso de
máscaras y eso tiene que venir
claramente del gobierno
cuando todo usted nos habla de que sería
un pequeño tercer pico de las muertes y
contagios en eeuu en europa que está
viendo una segunda ola de contagios que
está aumentando por ejemplo en francia
superan los 10.000 casos al día por
segunda vez pues eeuu prepararse para
una segunda ola de las nuevas
proporciones de la primera que se vivió
más o menos en marzo y abril
no creo que sea de tal magnitud pero
estamos muy preocupados porque estamos
empezando el otoño donde estamos por ver
qué es lo que ocurre con la influenza y
otros vivos hemos empezado una campaña
gastón ya para los honores de la salud
más precoz que los años pero así todos
estamos muy expectantes porque bueno no
sabemos esta pandemia y esta epidemia
que totalmente tenemos los inviernos de
influenza y de rinovirus o virus
sincitial respiratorio va a influir en
él en la hospitalización de más casos
esperemos que esta ola que vaya a ver en
lo posible en el doctor yo viene el
invierno no sea de tal magnitud
vuelvo a repetir algo que vengo diciendo
nosotros si bien estamos viendo mayor
aumento de casos los casos no son tan
graves y severos como los que observamos
en la primera bola
doctor hay algunas estimaciones y
proyecciones de las cuales usted nos
puede hablar un poco más de que para
diciembre en eeuu por más de 350 mil 170
mil muertos por la enfermedad por el coi
19 con lo que usted nos acaba de contar
de que los casos son menos severos y
teniendo en cuenta tal vez la
experiencia médica usted cree que esa
cifra se va a alcanzar o que pronto va a
superar o va a ser menor de lo que se
espera
yo creo que soy optimista en ese aspecto
nadie sabe a ciencia cierta qué es lo
que puede ocurrir pero yo creo que
viendo que si bien los casos han
aumentados y la proporción de casos
graves y muertes no es tanto como la
primero la yo creo que en realidad no
vamos a llegar a esa cifra de muertos
pero espero tener razón y no equivocarme
puesto que sería realmente un número muy
importante pero grave para limpiar pues
agradecemos a oscar cingolani profesor
de medicina de la universidad johns
hopkins de estados unidos por estar
entre 94